I'm really, really flying in the sky right now. I
can't be a kid forever. I
can't work all the time.
And I'm not a lioness. It's
been a long time.
Oh, that's right. I'm
relying on Amber's eyesight.  I
wanted to get on board. The
search team on the ground is also important. If you look at the
oil you're looking for from the sky, you'll
find it easily. There's no chance of finding it.
Well, hoping for luck isn't science. We'll
be working with the ground team on our cell phones.  As we steadily
map the topography, we approach the oil fields we are looking for. We
will create a world map of the new world with our own eyes.
[Music]
That forest is a cedar forest.
Leave it to us for the material. The
route too.  I get it, there's a treasure trove of building materials over there. I'm
going to add treasure points to the map like I'm making a map for a game.
[Music] It's getting
pretty fun. I'll
consult with Chrom and look for mines.
Yeah, that's fine, that's fine, too.
[Music] It's
moving. It's a
herd of wild animals. You guessed it. The
sailor's face is
[Music] I
found a stray goat nearby. It's a
herd of feral goats. I'm
grateful and leave it behind, even though it's a herd of wild animals.  Let's Eat
From
[Music]